joséphine coleman verger qui nous
rejoint qui doit se demander ce qui
arrive ça vous quittez notre plateau
bonjour ça nous oblige de loisirs à
saint quentin en yvelines
on est plutôt pas mal on est plutôt
moyen d'installer oui c'est de calais on
va parler des activités proposées par le
département parce que vous êtes maire de
plaisir vice-présidente de 50 ans et
puis aussi vice présidente du conseil
départemental des yvelines
parlons déjà plus globalement de la
politique du tourisme à 50 dans les
yvelines pardon en général l'été période
importante et le département accompagne
ce tourisme alors que ce soit pour les
étrangers qui viennent des autres
départements que pour les yvelinois les
yvelinoises aussi oui bien sûr
aujourd'hui vous savez on a fait un
regroupement de développement
touristique avec le 92 comme vous le
savez et cette mission tourisme est
quelque chose de fondamental puisque on
s'est non seulement rendu compte parce
qu'on le savait depuis longtemps quand
même que ce département est un
département de grandes richesses
touristiques et de développement
économique ce qui n'est pas rien alors
comme vous le rappeliez et vous avez
raison de le dire on n'est pas
simplement un appel de tourisme une
départementale mais également
d'ile-de-france et voire internationale
je vous ferai pas l'affront de vous
rappeler les grands châteaux que nous
avons sur notre départ il n'y a pas de
versailles en c'est ça qu'il faut faire
découvrir aussi la pac versailles on a
énormément de château à visiter mais on
a pas que ça parce que je voudrais vous
dire en préambule c'est avant toute
chose avant de venir essayer de prendre
la carte pass malin parce que ça qui est
important avant que je vous décris tout
ce qui va se passer dans le départ c'est
une carte parce que c'est une carte
gratuite pour re 5 personnes
c'est-à-dire une famille pratiquement et
qui vous donne la possibilité d'avoir
une réduction de 15 % sur toutes les
activités illinois c'est à dire les
monuments mais aussi vous ça vous le
savez que nous avons des eaux vont
également des endroits pour faire je
dirais des des visites patrimoniales
historique donc tout ça passe mal un
avant tout je vous disponible notamment
dans les offices de tourisme
voilà tout à fait et c'est fondamental
de le dire on a des grandes
manifestations alors c'est vrai vous
avez raison
l'été n'est pas un moment où département
doit abandonner les yvelinois c'est un
département qui se dit que l'été il ya
beaucoup de gens qui partent certes mais
pas de moi ils partent une semaine
quinze jours donc il faut trouver des
activités
donc c'est ce que le
fait on a des grandes manifestations qui
vont avoir lu sur le département des
manifestations vous avez dû certainement
en parler avant même que je vous en
parle mais dd vous savez que sur
département le cyclisme est quelque
chose de fondamental est que nous allons
avoir à rambouillet la dernière étape du
tour de france c'est quand même pas rien
on vous dira s est pas divine qu'il dé
6,6 et quand même divine qui s'en
occupent l'angleterre venir des
touristes pour découvrir le reste du
département exactement et puis on a
aussi une grande manifestation au niveau
du mois d'août début août comme l'écrit
rando avec un rassemblement de mille
cavaliers ce qui n'est pas rien et 800
chevaux
tout ça au bréviaire c'est un espace qui
est vraiment dédié
je dirais à cette activité mais qui est
départementale il y a également vous
savez des grandes balades qui sont
organisées au niveau de tout ce qui est
vélo parce que nous avons le fameux
paris brest alors c'est pas de gâteau
mais jour presque tellement c'est un
plaisir de se balader en vélo sur ces
pistes cyclables que nous aménageons
puisque le département des yvelines est
un département cyclable qui est très
important on a aussi les nuits du cinéma
c'est pas rien ensuite à cannes il faut
bien être donc dans cette continuité
on a dans divers lieux du département
et bien cette manifestation qui
fonctionne très très bien le département
accompagne financièrement au niveau de
la com et accompagne également au niveau
de l'aménagement avec des chaises savez
pour presque dormir si le film ne vous
intéresse pas pour faire ça c'est
vraiment moi à la belle étoile
et puis bien sûr on a tous les réseaux
de visite des châteaux puis des maisons
des illustres puisque vous savez que les
impressionnistes c'est quand même
quelque chose de très important sur les
départements on a eu également une
grande manifestation qui va avoir lieu à
la fin de l'été début septembre dans le
parc du peuple de l'herbe
vous savez que ce parc a été
complètement aménagé par le département
113 hectares 18 millions d'euros
d'investissements sur ce parc avec toute
une série d'activités tourner vers les
familles particulièrement
mais début septembre c'est une grande
grande manifestation qui va avoir lieu
c'est la première fois et on espère
attirer plusieurs milliers de personnes
pour découvrir ce parc qui est un parc
bien sûr qu'ils aient départementale
complètement département pas et puis
j'en passe et des meilleurs vous avez
des manifestations à toit rigide dans le
parc de thoiry qui était un lieu mal
il faut absolument découvrir je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ça attire des gens de la
france entière
c'est bien si vous aviez un coup de
coeur dans le département un rendez vous
incontournable de l'été quelque chose à
découvrir peut-être de méconnu aussi
j'aurais tendance à dire le parc du
peuple de l'herbe quand même parce que
si vous voulez c'est ainsi un bras de la
seine
vous savez que la scène aussi est un
enjeu départementale puisque aujourd'hui
nous voulons vraiment développer l'axé
seine nous travaillons d'ailleurs avec
les cinq départements qui vont de paris
jusqu'au havre de façon à créer des
activités tout le long de cette scène
puisque durant de nombreuses années les
villes tourner le dos à la scène alors
qu'aujourd'hui on veut réintégrer et se
réapproprier la scène donc je dirais le
parc du peuple de l'herbe
parce qu'il ya des choses à voir à
visiter il ya de la faune et de la flore
et on a surtout reconstitué je dirais un
environnement qui est un environnement
yvelinois avec une une attirance je
dirais de développement durable de
biodiversité
et puis également d'activités pour tous
les âges donc c'est peut-être mon coup
de coeur de la nuit et concernant la
scène vous parliez tout à l'heure des
impressionnistes on sait que c'est un
lieu d'histoire aussi pour ses
impressionniste on l'a vu un reportage
tout à l'heure bien sûr c'est un lieu
d'histoire et puis si vous le permettez
je
j'aimerais bien vous dire deux mots de
bougival et du grand projet de bougival
parce que comme vous le savez il ya un
grand projet qui est en train de naître
autour autour de la maison de bizet
puisque le département a fait
l'acquisition de la maison de bizet ce
qui n'est pas rien mais également autour
de la datcha de tourguéniev est
également de la villa viardot qui a été
accompagné par monsieur berne comme vous
le savez pas par monsieur berne mais
nous par l'intermédiaire de monsieur des
moines président de la république est
venu sur place pour voir ce projet
puisque là il doit ya voir la naissance
d'un centre européen musical qui
aujourd'hui est accompagnée
véritablement par le gouvernement et par
l'europe donc là aussi vous le disiez il
ya des impressionnistes qui sont à
proximité
et on a aussi ses maisons des illustres
que nous essayons aujourd'hui de faire
vivre et de faire naître il ya une carte
qui est sorti justement dans les
yvelines avec un descriptif très précis
de tous ces endroits
ad
couvrir qui sont des endroits comme vous
le disiez historique patrimoniaux et
également de loisirs on a sur la scène
des endroits magnifiques de loisirs si
vous aimez l'eau il faut il faut y aller
parce qu'il ya des activités sportives
qui sont vraiment à développer et puis
de l'accrobranche enfin c'est un
département qui vaut la peine
le département très riche la carte vous
la retrouverez dans les offices de
tourisme notamment et c'est là aussi où
vous trouverez ce fameux passe mal an
dont nous parlions tout à l'heure pour
avoir des réductions là sur toutes les
activités qui sont proposées dans le
département merci beaucoup
comme anne verger